- Before we get to anything
I have something to tell you.
Judd Apatow told me that, and
I want to know if it's true.
He told me that it's your fault
that people scream my
name everywhere I go.
Ah Kelly Clarkson everywhere I go.
I could literally do anything
and it doesn't matter
how many hits what I do in life
I could save a family from drowning fires
I could do anything and
literally the one thing
that people know me from
is, ah Kelly Clarkson.
So is this true?
- Well I'm terribly sorry first of all.
I owe you an apology.
- No its awesome.
(giggles)
- [Seth] It is true,
yes, that is true it was
I was a co-producer on
the 40 Year Old Virgin.
I was also in it but it was,
I was a writer mostly by trade
at the time so I was hired
to write also like jokes.
We call them alt jokes or alternate jokes
and we knew Carell was going to be waxed.
And he wouldn't be able to
think clearly, probably.
So we wanted to just be able
to feed him things to say
and we don't always like
to only have profanity.
So Judd was like you should
write a list of jokes that are
like dirty jokes like and
a list of clean jokes.
And it was hard to write the clean jokes.
And I honestly think I
was sitting on my couch
writing the jokes and
you came on television
and I saw knew it was Kelly
Clarkson and in comedy
there's a thing with like
co sounds like they say
like comedy K like thinking
like a K sound is known
for being funny in the comedy world.
- [Kelly] I didn't know that.
- [Seth] And so I saw your
name and it was Kelly Clarkson
and there it was there's
an actual picture of.
- [Kelly] I'm in between burger panties
and throbbing monkey tail, I like it.
- [Seth] I would do that list but
it has to be completely blurred out.
You see I stuck to the assignment though.
Really, I'm doing what half of clean jokes
and one half of dirty jokes.
(laughter)
- Throbbing monkey tail.
- Yeah well.
- That's awesome.
- I thank god that people don't
scream that at you when you walk around.
- I am just saying I loved it so much.
I did, actually, I literally
was coming into a theater.
How I first heard it, was in a preview.
I was coming into a theater
to watch a different movie
and I was with friends and we were late
because you know I got
to hit up concessions
for some popcorn m&ms and
so we came in a little late
and we were like coming in
and I was like and everybody
was like and I thought
somebody in the theater
yelled my name, I didn't
know what just happened.
Cause I was like, what,
And that's how I found out.
They were like, they yelled your name
in that trailer, And I was like, why?
And then I was anyway and it's literally
I can be Japan it doesn't matter where
the hell I am Seth, people,
since you've been gone
never heard of it but Kelly
Clarkson's name being yelled
during a waxing that's what
they know, it's amazing.